waren the one touches in a power play situation
making sure you get open make sure you face the
passer and as quick as possible get the puck on
that dowy left Circle off the draw toward the
middle long shot they score Byfield from the Blue
Line deflected in front and 61 seconds in it's one
nothing La back at the Blue Line by field on the
boards get it back look at this he Sprints right
to the middle this is a set play you have the
screen I don't think it hit anything other than
marrom marrom did get a piece of it there was
a moving screen by Kee but this these are the
things you work on you talk about procise pass
looking for Jordan Spence the defenseman tried
to Center deflected behind the net den know takes
away feeds it for fiala centers quick shot kick
save marstrom Flames will take it pass toward the
middle it rolled off of mapani tries to collect
for Calgary forces it toward the right side and
now Rasmus Anderson his shot scores deflected in
front looked like it went off talit and just
a minute or so later the Flames tied the game
one and one by the reaction of Camp taet we'll
see if it changes directions I assume it does
you see the knuckle effect was it the skate of
Matt Roy we'll get a better look down low it's
it looks like it's going in low but then it hits
something ends up about shoulder height Trevor
Moore sends it toward the Blue Line Roy left side
moar is shot tipped in front and blocked rebound
of the circle for Den treding to Center again
from a sharp angle loose puck in front whacked
at by Moore and covered by marrom puck bouncing
around between the circles and now the Flames
will send it into the neutral zone Dodie throws
a big check and knocks down Greer as the Flames
come in right side tip toward the middle wrist
shot saved by talvin first Power Play opportunity
of the game for either side try to dig it up
the wall toward the middle one timer from Kee
held on to by marstrom now there it was calry
goal score Kings try to hold it in dubock right
Circle rolls it back to the near side for fil itel
and now up top Spence Waits shoots tiic but they
score right at the end of the power play
and pl Dubois tips it in his six of the
year it's 21 la it's a high tip but there
certainly was more energy he's right there
hand ey coordination actually bounced one
time off the stick then I believe the ice
here yes it does stick ice then another bounce
but it's all about facing the shooter it's
all about getting yourself home rebound
for Conor Zer hands it off up the left
wing and ahead comes cadri nice move into
the Zone cadri in front trying to to pull
the trigger had it knocked off his stick
from behind and the King sent it down the
ice the captain backin turns it over poked
in by lafier up the left wing in a two-on
one lefer drops it back and a shot fired wide
and then a wraparound chance on the backand
for lafier couple of Jabs at it in front but
it keeps its way away from the net and the
Flames back to neutral ice example how simple
can be eff of lafier once again outside speed
huberto skated it in and now Dubois moves it
for the middle and Jacob moara starts it up
for the kings boy up the right wing tipped in
no icing and markstrom out to get it turned
it over in front and Byfield weights tipped
toward the goal and a save by marstrom duban
tried to send it back up top from between the
circles but intercepted and cleared back to
the king's end with 40 seconds off the power
play Spence will Speed Ahead turn it tried to
drop it back intercepted by Coleman here they
come short-handed two onone in front and they
score this is just taking advantage of
a turnover but across spread out ooh he
gets smun back copar down the wall and now up
top right Circle Kee shoots save loose Puck
and markstrom holds on for a whistle with
22 seconds left on the penalty to tan of
course she said yes she's one happy camper and
they came together separate to go home as one
22 game here in Downtown LA dowy throws
it back in front tipped toward the goal
score tipped in front DuBois was there back
post lafier was there and the Kings retake
the lead it's 3-2 with 1332 left in the second
he gets a kick on it I believe we'll see what
happens skate behind bang is it over the
line yet Kings don't care and theair it's
a deflection you see he does not take a kick
at it it's in behind as the Flames start their
first Power Play of the game Circle Zer tipped
in front loose Puck knocked Away by talit and
the Kings will flare it back to Center ice
not only to deny an initial shot but to make
sure there's no second chance that's a key
when you're on the penalty Stripped Away
King short-handed in front backhanded toward
the goal by lazat but kept out by markstrom
now the flame still can't get it out another
tip on it from lazad and markstrom's going to
come out shuffle the puck away through the
neutral zone up the right wing leaves it
in front nearly found its way through maybe
not intentionally but slowly rolled through
the circles never forcing things but see if the
Kings can get one here and comes more shoots and
scores Trevor Moore in a Flash and it's 42 La
this game and the Kings have played well enough
to have a two- goal Lead watch release man there
might be a stick involved on we uh hanin here but
yeah there probably was good to see the Kings
attacking from down low around the crease and
then from back up high top the umbrella fl's
trying to throw it in front there there with
leager but then knocked up the wall Kee finds it
in the neutral zone Kee shoots knocked out rebound
pped away from by field faceoffs would have been
outside and the penalty Co get a little rest not
the case anymore have to take a face off in
your own Zone again eager starts it through
the neutral zone and up the left wing cross
ice in front quick shot saved by talit final
minute of the Flames power play here to start the
third Zer for the bottom of the circle back back
handed at front save talin rebound scooped up by
copar and then Scoops it back up again and will
backhand it over the neutral zone and bouncing
back into the flames and with 40 seconds to go on
the kill 35 seconds to go on the penalty to Carl
grundstrom LS in the left corner trying to take
it back up top more active on the kill right side
ritka shoots kick save rebound they score Blake
Coleman has a shorty and he's got a power play
goal and it's 4-3 Kings with 12 42 left in the
third and you'll see this the bounce works here
for the Flames save rebound and it's the second
way much like earlier where the Kings had two men
in front watch the Flames with two men in front
Bin's in front and Coleman's in front you already
have the man Advantage you're going to outnumber
the opposition down for tanv it away from BL and
then the C taken away comes fi away shoots save
Mark still six on five Skating here with marstrom
out of the net to face off in front of Cam talit
and off the draw Kings pick it up roll down the
ice by Kee foot race for it bfield after it he
scores QB into the empty net and it's 53 La
man Quinton Byfield has been timed he's been
measured yes ke's go but you know what
he knows he know knows he has one of the
fastest players in the league along with him
on the ice and look at there Han as soon as
Hanah maybe it's back speed 23 mph on
that one and glove down by Anderson in
the neutral zone Toom it looking for
it then turn and swung toward the net
and wide it won't matter the Kings with
an impressive 53 win tonight on home ice